welcome back y'all i'm kicking it with kim whitley
and an audience full of single ladies give it
up y'all it is part two of our single ladies
celebration and who knows how many parts of this
celebration we will have it's up to us i own the
show we're gonna do whatever we want um only time
in the bottoms of our our bottomless beverages
will tell not bottomless justin just the one we'll
do um during our very first celebration we had
many women in our audience share their stories and
ask questions they were enlightening empowering
and many were just hilariously funny um so we
want to hear some more because it was fun so let's
start with madison what's your single life like
madison hi kelly and kim um it's going well so
i've enjoyed being single i've enjoyed having this
time to really just get to know myself and learn
more about myself on a deeper level however not
everyone views being single as a positive thing
and they feel sorry for me and they're constantly
trying to set me up on date so one of those people
being my grandma she could just not accept me
being single so she set me up on three blind dates
before she passed away one of them was with a guy
um that she met at a coffee shop that she went
too often um he was in a band and she thought
he was like the greatest thing that walked this
planet don't do it and so i finally gave in and
i was like okay so i went on one date with him
only to discover upon seeing him that he was
my school's drug dealer what yeah i didn't i
didn't see that one coming here's my question
ma'am how did you know he was the
drug dealer you took it you took it
yeah i was gonna get there actually so
everyone knew like everyone knew his name
disclaimer i did not use his services i
promise i'm not judging just wondering
but immediately i recognized him just
because like everyone kind of knew who he was
um and so let's just say that date did not go as
planned um i loved my grandma dearly but you know
she sure knew how to pick them aren't glenn dates
the best so my question to you is what's the worst
playing date experience that you've ever had oh
wow well first of all uh applause to your grandma
you know a grandma three times dead uh her grandma
she was really looking out for to be in the coffee
shop to go up to a stranger and say uh look uh
my uh desperate granddaughter uh i mean why the
worst what in the world i hear grandma what i love
her grandma what are she saying to these people
um for me i have had a lot of bad ones but i've
enjoyed every experience but my experience was
kind of like hers my girlfriend was telling me
about this guy and how nice he was but she never
said his name she was just like one day you know
you're going to meet you got to meet him i got
to hook you guys up and it was the same thing we
were at a restaurant she was like come come come
on come on go he's here he's here come on come
on we're we're having some to eat and i walk in
and it's my cousin no it is like but it's a
distant cousin she didn't know you know it's like
your third cousin i know it was horrible i walked
in he sees me i see him we got the same dimples
everything else oh my god oh it was horrible she
or funny it was we laughed oh we were dying oh my
god she felt so bad because she was like i should
have said the name i should have told you i said i
i asked you what was he made oh my god and so
that was probably my uh how horrible i've never
been on a blind date so after i kissed him no go
ahead i'm just playing he is my cousin kissing
no i've never been on a blind date i don't know
that i would do a blind date not yet yeah you
would i don't know i called you and said so no i
mean no he's everything i've checked him out i've
vetted him just just come on and just meet him
okay no but if he's everything why are you passing
them on to me because you have to understand
i already got seven of them lined up over here
i'm giving you number eight i don't i don't think
i'd do a blind i think i really no i don't think i
i'm not already nervous enough if i know the dude
not even just for the fun no i don't think that
would be fun i think that would be terrifying
really really i need you to live i'm sweating
right now just thinking about it it's so much
fun i'm also in spanx and drinking okay yeah
yeah you would not do a blind date i don't think
so but whatever you know why because it's not fair
at this point it's not fair if i weren't famous
i would do a blind date but that's not fair it's
not blind for them no they don't what if they
don't test say well they walk in the freaking
restaurant and see my face or hear my voice
they're going and then i know nothing about
them no what if your girlfriend says here he is on
paper this is everything about okay okay okay if
it's not like completely blind right some kind
of like you got it what if she shows there's a
catalog i'm like picking it right that was gonna
say where's the camera and she shows you a picture
and said i didn't tell him who you were but i told
him you're very nice and okay i might do something
like that okay not now but like way longer right
now yeah well you say way long like 20 years
because i'm dating myself and i'm enjoying
it hey okay wait a minute y'all that's true
that's true that was a good i like dating myself
thank you so much madison yeah i date myself too
and i ghosted myself too i got it okay okay i
went too far i went too hard i have to be the
party kim because no one's actually here i'm a
practicer we are well into part d of our single
ladies celebration and we're chatting it up with
our fellow single ladies in the audience and flat
out enjoying our best selves on our own so let's
keep the train moving with talisha hi talisha
hi hi kelly hi kim all right let me tell you so
i've been celebrating being happily single for
a little minute you know i don't want just
any relationship i want the relationship
so i'm not rushing it i'm sitting back chilling
you know minding my business and i think guys
just kind of take it the wrong way like i've been
told a couple times by different um single men
they don't approach me because i look married
already right um so i asked them what they
meant and they said because i don't look single
and desperate well who wants on the other hand
what in the world on the other end of that coin
though i'm constantly approached by married men
to have affairs because i'm married already you
know so i guess now i too have something to lose
what what's the what's the worst compliment you've
gotten from a guy oh oh that i'm still at how you
look married what you got on you got on some memes
some slippers and a captain what are you watching
around how are you looking you've got rollers
in your head and you're over it what's happening
you look happy i don't know what's that i
don't know what that means yeah like you don't
look desperate i'm like do you want me to look
desperate that says more about you dude than me
um that's really weird take that the worst
thing a guy's ever said you know what this is
this person might know who i'm talking about
but here's the thing i didn't i wasn't really
feeling it like i was into somebody else and
and i didn't want to tell anyone because i'm
pretty shy and anyway so this other person was
trying to set me up with someone that they knew
and i was like oh god i don't want to
look like i'm interested in this person so
anyway finally this girlfriend like wore
me down to give she was like can i please
just give your number to him i promise you
he's so cool this is why i don't do that
i like it i like it anyway she was like i promised
she was great blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
then finally i'm like oh just give my number just
if it makes you feel awkward and i'll just i'll
shut it down like nicely like because i was into
someone so and i'm very focused and so anyway i
got a first text from him it was either the
very first text or the second text and if it
wasn't the first text and the first text was high
kelly and the second text was you have a nice ass
and i was like was he black i literally no no that
was his second that was his introduction to me
you have a nice ass and i i literally just
texted back charming and i changed my number
this is a woman with an ass let me explain to
y'all what no that's because you got an ass women
with little asses like me if i got one text and
man said you got a nice ass i mean like for real
no no that's his first like entrance like
that's like something you said you've been
dating a minute and i'm maybe i'm like oh i have
a little fat in this like that's something you
saw in there like no i have a nice ass not
like the first time you talk to me like i
don't have time for that all right you might
be yeah right i wish i just want one of the
cameramen the sound people the band members
hey bad i'm taking i'll take it say it again
you made him sing with that with that
what's the worst thing that any any guy
like ever lie any longer okay um he said oh
my god you have your father's lips wait wait
so what are you going to want to kiss
them at some point because now i feel like
i'm uncomfortable oh you look like your
brother without hair okay everybody's gone
it's over yes i i've had men say crazy things
i've had men shower me with money after a
comedy show he just gave me all this money like
i could be bought after i picked up all the money
i was like no i'm not interested but thank
you i was like ridiculous this will scare you
oh my gosh well thank you so much to lisa and
i think you look fabulous any way you want to
look and you don't you know what i see that as
you're picking the weeds you know you haven't
found the flowers so that's all right i've got
kim whitley on one hand and a mojito in the other
and an audience of awesome single ladies life is
good everybody it is part two of our single ladies
celebration hanging out and swapping stories next
up we've got juanita let's tell your story juanita
hi kelly hi kim um i am celebrating being
single currently uh my last relationship left
my self-esteem pretty low i've been building
it up for the last four years of being single
um i like my butt i like my legs and i love my
smile you know so something i've been looking into
is a boudoir photo shoot for myself i even have a
little outfit picked out it's pink and black and
gonna make me feel so confident what's something
you've done for your sexy single self wait wait
wait wait we're going back to you yeah she she
said she got a little pink outfit she about to get
naked on the couch be like this wait wait wait
what's this is it a good what that's the bedroom
booth wise french or something french span
or something wait what is that wait so you
what what do you do there's sexy photo shoot
for yourself a sexy photo shoot in the boudoir
here's the thing when you are in the public eye
you never allow a camera near your naked behind
you might cover it up a little bit i'd like to i'd
like to do that scene in uh nine and a half weeks
uh with kim basinger remember the food on their
body i want to take a picture and the food was
like i'd like to put some um some ribs like a
little that just seems like a waste of good food
no i didn't say it was gonna be wasted now
we're gonna put some ribs or a rack of lamb
can you imagine to take a picture with a rib
in my mouth and in the booth no i just i think
that that makes you feel really good and i love
that you said you love your butt and your smile
and and all the things about you know i'm sorry
that you're in a relationship where somebody
um you know kind of took that from you for
a minute um but here's the thing like never
let them have that power in the first place
like because i don't know there's so you know
something everybody likes something different so
it's like okay cool you're not into it somebody
else might be you know so um i don't know i
say never put your eggs in their basket ever
keep them in your basket that's right yeah
and accidentally send the pictures out oh
only if they look good in their body right and
the lighting is going to be i don't know how you
got that picture that's crazy i'm like yeah i
do that all the time oops that's crazy yeah all
i'm saying if people say they got naked picture me
they lying because i would never do that ain't no
cameras around no and you know people know those
cameras there because no one looks like that in
those things you know they're all like perfectly
lit and they're just like you know nobody looks
like that when you're making everybody looks weird
yeah yeah thank you so much juanita um all right
you guys have been bringing it with the stories
uh but before we go to break i want to thank you
all for sharing by serving up a little pampering
because i think it's nice to do that for everybody
soothe brings licensed and trained wellness
professionals directly to your home or office
with massage hair or beauty services to choose
from soothe brings everything you need to treat
yourself to a day of self care everyone in the
house seats is getting a 200 gift card for supe
yup i'm still here just
waiting for you to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box forever